first skill I want to talk about is
business Acumen and maybe you might
already wonder whether this is actually
your skill or whether this isn't
something that people naturally have or
don't have I strongly believe that
business a human isn't learned and can
be developed my perspective it is the
implicit knowledge the implicit
understanding of business situations it
is a bit of an intuition that you will
form over time what the right decision
is for a business or maybe also what
just does not make sense to follow it
all and in my experience an absolutely
necessary condition to build business a
human is an understanding of fundamental
technical Topics in business and this
will be especially things like
accounting and finance